o psol e 20 e hoje vou ensinar como
fazer um canhão que disparam povo de
israel só o futebol de seu pêndulo outra
coisa qualquer que caiba dentro do gum
elas façam este projecto não se esqueçam
de usar óculos de proteção noite para
encontrar ninguém esforçarem por que nos
peçam ajuda de um adulto para
supervisionar e os dados de fabricar e
isto agora vamos lançar o primeiro
envolve a folha como se fosse uma rifa
caso vocês não consigam fazer espírito
eu vou deixar minha discrição ensina a
fazer isso mais devagar passo a passo
pois você nem rifa e voleibol foi a
volta do modo a fazer um clean
no final nos que são pra ver com fita
por não ser o alho
faça o terrir fomos ao contrário da
primeira essa tem ficar louca por dentro
entendo assim depois paula
o quarto em parte mais frágil e marca em
500 corta enm e guarda os pedaços para
ser usado por isso corta um pedaço tudo
com 15 em picos
aproveitando a parte sobrou do estudo o
quarto tempo da acontecem dentro e
marque um maiô ou seja 5 centímetro dos
lados para um clube assim que sobrou tem
exatamente cinco centímetros e vão
precisar de mais tarde começa a impor
juntar a partir de 15 centímetros do
tubo com 15 centímetros da
fifa/coca-cola tiver ficado tem que
pintar a parte de 10 centímetros mas
atenção só cinco cintos e ficam colados
na parte de rita e ali podem ficar entre
os dois tons
não cola no maior do segmento colado de
cinco centros e cola em um processo
químico sobrou dos cinco centímetros
negro veicular conca modo uma rifa do
modo que vocês estão vendo aqui no vídeo
cole depois tem que ajustar o tamanho
dessas partes mais frágeis que sobraram
é modo fica o tamanho do dever que eu
tenho 65 cm o time acabara de 21
sentindo e não tem que acabar transporte
da elefanta para fazer questão da arma
um sábado na rifa e elásticos
eu vou usar e que alguns elásticos
porque os meus negócios são fracos mas
se vocês tiverem mais fortes não seja
usada para fazer o que lhe vão precisar
simplesmente um contágio maior fã do
quarto e parte mais frágil de um dos
lados e corta encosta da informação mais
ou menos 45 garros
é justo em um tamanho modo e com pedaços
um para fora e prontos esta foi para
finalizar a parte cultural de opinião
precisaram de duas tampinhas e um action
para isso vou usar um pulinho escutado
faça um buraco na parte central das
tampas
e qual é o modo que vocês estão vendo
aqui no vídeo
o importante é que você deixa assim o
juramento folgado a quem não deixem as
rodas muito apertadas contra o segmento
dos cinco centímetros de papel para
finalizar um precisar de um pouco de
super cola procura neste disparo
isso vai aumentar bastante resistência e
se vocês não quiserem é provável que não
vá funcionar muito bem ok então é
extremamente portanto vocês ponham
supergol e pronto já está feito agora
vejam como carregar a arma e disparar
então isso aí só os ganhos no fim eu
espero que tenham gostado se você
estiver em alguma ideia ou sugestão é só
deixar os comentários se fizeram sejam
responsáveis noite para enquanto ninguém
e isso tomar tal até a próxima